Now that we've configured
our repositories,
we can define dependencies on artifacts
contained in those repositories.
Dependencies that are resolved from
repositories are referred to as external
module dependencies.
Dependencies are assigned
to configurations.
We'll talk more about configurations
in detail later, but for
now you can simply consider them to
be groups of related dependencies.
For the examples here,
we'll be adding dependencies to
the compile configuration,
which is added by the Java plugin.
Dependencies are configured in
the dependencies script block.
The syntax used is the name of
the configuration we want to add
the dependency to followed
by a dependency notation.
We can also use a Groovy map syntax
to identify dependencies, again,
by their group,
their name and their version.
In some cases, we simply have files
we want to add as dependencies.
File dependencies are declared very
similarly to manage dependencies,
however instead of a dependency notation
we simply use a file collection or
a file tree.
In this example, we are simply
adding two JAR files as dependencies
by creating a file collection.
We can also use a file tree,
which allows us to do things
like specify filters.
This is useful for including a number
of files within a directory.
Gradle also supports project
dependencies, which are dependencies on
other Gradle projects within
a single multi-project build.
We'll talk more about
multi-project builds and
project dependencies in the next lesson.